alors en france l'inquiétude de la
population se traduit par une baisse des
ventes des volailles d'environ 20%
le ministre de l'agriculture dominique
bussereau s'étonne et dénonce la
psychose il a annoncé aujourd'hui la
création d'un logo volaille française et
ce dès lundi dans les magasins on
l'écouté vraiment dire au consommateur
que il n'y a aucun souci de manger du
poulet il n'ya pas d'épisode chimie en
france il n'y en a aucune
en europe des 25 les quelques cas qui
sont apparus par exemple en grèce on
s'est aperçu que c'était pas du virus
h5n1
donc c'est vraiment pas le moment de
s'affoler nous allons nous-mêmes
remettre en place un centre
d'information comme ça a été le cas pour
les problèmes de viande bovine avec
numéro vert avec un site internet afin
de donner aux consommateurs toutes les
informations qu'on direct et des
informations les plus précises possibles